[Music]
all right up next is tanner from north
carolina hey tanner welcome to the show
hi rachel and george
how are you doing
i'm doing great how are you we're doing
well how can we help
i had a quick question i'm currently 19
years old i drive a 300 000 mile vehicle
it runs fantastic and i have no problems
thus far with it but um i was wondering
what is the age to stop spending on once
and start spending on the future i
always hear people say oh i wish i'd
started this or that
does that mean they started 22 or 25 or
19.
my my real question is i'm looking to
when this vehicle dies
to maybe get a nicer vehicle obviously
pay cash for it
but i was thinking something around the
30 000
dollar mark with uh get something cool
and fun like a muscle car
um would this be a wise choice or should
i um perhaps get another six thousand
dollar vehicle it'll last for
another five or six years
and then
invest that money in a down payment or
something like that yeah great question
tanner are you in school right now are
you working what's kind of your status
i'm currently working um i do a side
hustle and i also have a main job okay
and how much do you make a year
um
approximately thirty thousand dollars
combined
okay
so our rule of thumb just to answer the
car question and george can jump into
the kind of the lifestyle question but
the
the car we always say that you don't
want anything on wheels
to be half of your annual income
so if you were to go and save up for a
30 000 car
uh while you're making 30 000 that would
not be smart because that would mean
most of what you're making is your net
worth is in your car uh so if you were
still making 30 i would shoot for a 15
000 car at the most but you can still
get a great car
for 10
12 000 you know even even below fifteen
thousand so
um if you have the cash and you're able
to
uh pay for it in full then that's kind
of where i would recommend do you have
um do you have any debt right now
i do not no doubt how much money do you
have in the bank
um
so
i was a little unwise with spending um
so about three months ago i had probably
about a hundred dollars
i've thus tightened down in the last
three months i've accumulated 8 500
dollars um you're working and just
really uh you must be saving every penny
man
yeah yeah definitely on
big change wow well to your original
question you said what's the proper age
to stop spending on wants and plan for
the future
and the truth is you're always going to
be buying things that you want and you
should always be planning for the future
so i don't see them as mutually
exclusive i see them as things you
factor into your monthly budget so have
some things that you're looking forward
to some short-term goals but also be
investing for the future in a retirement
plan do you have any kind of plan
through your employer right now for that
there is a plan through my employer but
currently i'm not i'm signed up for that
okay now i do want you to have a fully
funded emergency fund which may be that
8 500 you're sitting on which means
we're not going to touch it for the car
we need to set up a different savings
account to start saving up for that next
car
yeah so i would probably honestly if i
were you tanner just because it has 300
000 miles on it which is awesome that
you've literally driven it to that point
but it's it's probably getting close to
its last leg there just from a mileage
perspective what kind of car is this i'm
just curious
it is a 2007 ford edge ford edge all
right let's go forward i was gonna
assume toyota i was gonna say a camry
camry is where i would put my money but
i
toyota toyota i get made fun of for how
i say it what do you say i say toyota
it's toy sorry tanner i'm so sorry you
got to hear that through the phone
that's a terrible thing
way to go forward making the car yeah
that's a long time so tanner
i would do your emergency fund which
again george site could be that 8500 and
then i probably would sit there and save
a little bit more cash because what i
don't want to happen is that that
wonderful ford with 300 000 miles
suddenly becomes undrivable and you're
like oh gosh and then you have to dip
into your emergency fund so i would
start saving on the side for a car
um but i would only do that for maybe i
don't know what would you say george
maybe six seven months and then i would
start investing so i would kind of do
both at the same time but i would jump
start to that car fund
um even before investing because of what
it's going to cost you yeah and i would
definitely try to get your income up
because you're working you said you have
a full-time job and a side hustle and
you're pulling in 30 000. um what kind
of job is this
i'm a
technician for uh i pull fiber
and data cables for
installing things such as printer jacks
that you plug into your printer
setting up server towers cool that kind
of stuff i would see what roles in that
industry you could step into grow into
even talk to your employer about what
growth looks like i mean you're 19. you
get your whole life ahead of you i've no
doubt you're going to do great but i
think with that income it's going to be
harder to save up it's going to be
harder to invest harder to get a down
payment making 30 000. yeah so you're on
you're on the right track though tana
you're doing doing an awesome job